So let's talk about Distributed Management tools and
these are I think - are not so dissimilar from
normal management tools or at least these days, with everything presenting a
web interface,
in order to make them easy to use, then the things that you would use to manage
a distributed team given the tools that are available online
are very similar to the ones that you would use for a centralized or co-located team.
The particular ones that are bouncing around in the front of my cortex
at the moment are many things that you will already be familiar with
such as a Wikis, Google Docs;
here I am in Google Docs; Pivotal Tracker we're big fans of
Pivotal Tracker; and there's others that we've ... various
people on our team have had different experiences with, there's like Jira, Trello, Asana:
all different tools for sort of tracking the
tasks that you've got to do ... what gets done, who's doing it and so on
and in some ways the ... default thing is
... in order to do shared work
you just need some kind of something you know
a document that you'll be able to pass around and so
for example; I keep thinking back, I can remember
a setup where the planning document might have been in a Word document
and that might have been emailed round to people and
you know that maybe it would end up getting stored in a version control
system and the problem
with those kind of things is you know, again whether you're a single team in a
single office,
or spread out all over the world, just visibility
is a terrible problem so and you know people "Oh it's in the
Word document", "Where kind of is that?" If you've got and everybody's got browsers running all the
time -
if you've got a Wiki ... like we've got an example here GitHub Wiki
you know it's a simple as saying "Oh right, yes I need ...
some information on let's kind of go, here AgileVentures, LocalSupport"
and I go to my LocalSupport Wiki
there and I've got some information and ... basically
anybody can start updating and trying to fix problems in that and we've got
great visibility there.  So that's kind of like a great default
thing ... tends to be I mean - you know there are restrictions… You
know Wikis usually have various restrictions
on formatting ... Atlassian who produced Jira they also do
you know an enterprise grade Wiki ... you get more,
I guess the more you pay for it more bang you get your buck ... although GitHub
Wikis
... we have Wikis for all of our AgileVentures products
... Google Docs provides more formatting options:
for the development of this class we've got a shared
google doc folder that's got all the slides in it, everybody on the team can edit any of the slides at anytime
... we've got this great thing in Google Docs as you're probably aware
there's great features to show; have I got something down here, no one else looking at this slide
at the same time as me, but it shows you when someone else is looking at the
same
... the same slide to try and help you avoid editing
two things at the same time ... you know so you can kind of get away
to a degree with Wikis and Google docs and so on ...
I guess - beyond the Wiki at least - you've got your issue tracker
which often shows up in the pull requests; pull requests; where's my issues gone ...
graphs, network, bu du du der, LocalSupport go back
... do we not have a ... because normally pull requests become
I can see that there, mmm, maybe we don't actually ...
we don't use I think ... I notice quite a few ... I mean there's a fantastic
issues ... I think we have some ... yeah, there we go
... there's a ... I think many projects don't
don't tend to use GitHub issues as a tracking system.
It's certainly there; some do
and the issue tracking there is great ...
we tend to use Pivotal Tracker across the board and rather than me
explaining Pivotal Tracker to you which your
at least partly familiar with we've got two videos from Pivotal Labs
in the next two sections showing a general introduction to
Pivotal Tracker and a more detailed
you know how Pivotal Tracker works with the whole sort of Scrum process
and so on ... Jira as a paid tool; I don't have so much experience with that
... other members of our team
you know, like it; other groups I know swear by it; I know people who prefer
Trello, I know people who prefer Asana
... they've all got their relative pros and cons
but one of the things that we notice about all of these things is basically that they're
available
over the web ... available transparently ...
I mean this is the key for managing all of our projects as you can
see here
I've got all the different AgileVenture projects that are ongoing, here, I can jump to any of them
quickly.
Anybody, you know, we just pass the link around, anyone can see it anyone can get in
there
and see what's going on ... also particularly relevant to
the 169 class - if I go and look up through the
the whole projects here - in terms of managing the content for the MOOC
we've always used ... (that's autograders
which is also for the MOOC but 169, there we go); so for example
we've got here in previous runs
of the MOOC we've tracked all of the issues
and bug reports and so on about the course
through these trackers ... and we did and we were at one point running
sort of competitions for who could file the most reports.
I believe I've already created one for ... here we go, so this is
our next run ...
so this - this is something that ... we'll get all of the
TA's
signed up to as members - and then for you know
triage obviously we can discuss issues in the stack exchange forum, which
we've now got up and working; I mean sort of I haven't really mentioned
forums in particular there because we'll have more on the forums
next week but obviously issues can be kind of triaged and discussed
and so on in the forum but
ultimately in terms of generating like work that has to be done by somebody
... so this is like something I know I'm just going to have to do
for the new course ... it can be you set there -
(and I know that just has to be done so let's just pop that over there)
... I think Pivotal Tracker is a great
online free resource and we'll be using it
for managing the MOOC. I think it's a fantastic
tool for supporting Scrum, the whole Agile
process generally as you can see we use its extensively
for all of our AgileVenture projects and
yeah so I'd strongly encourage you to watch the next couple of videos introducing you to Pivotal Tracker
if you're not
already fantastically familiar with it
already. It is of course introduced, in part, in the 169 course
and then we'll have an assignment to get started making sure
everybody's signed up as a member for this so that's as you go into being a TA
in the 169 course that we can coordinate
the work that needs to be done to fix various issues
in the class to make sure that the students have the best
course available to them.  Alright bye for now